[Music]
hi there Steve Kaufman here again this
is a short I hope follow-up video to the
one I did about learning German
there were several comments one and I've
heard this recently that my sound is too
low I've finally decided to try other
things other than adjusting the input
volume I got rid of my blue snowball
which I thought was a better microphone
I'm using this snowflake here and it
seems that the sound is lower louder
we'll see there were also some comments
that they would have people would have
liked to have me talk a bit more about
the specifics of learning German so I'll
attempt to do that
I'm okis mostly on motivation because to
me in all language learning motivation
is is by far the biggest factor and so
you have to find a reason to want to
learn this language and I suggested that
perhaps up front German may appeal
appear less motivating I mean one big
problem is you go to Germany and a lot
of speak people speak English
so that's demote demotivating if you
want to practice your german the other
thing is you know german is perceived as
as not it's not a romantic language it's
not perceived as as the language of love
like Italian and so forth we listen to
Italian and Spanish music singers I
personally don't listen to any German
singers German music as in classical
music of course but not in so far as
modern music is concerned you know we
have this phenomenon of the Korean drama
which creates a lot of interest in
Korean we have Japanese anime which
creates a lot of interest in in Japanese
I think for whatever reason Germany
despite its economic power doesn't seem
to have the same in so far as modern
culture is concerned the same universal
appeal as as others now I'm speaking
perhaps from ignorance I know there are
people who like German rock music's come
up at our forum at length so further I
don't even know what it is
so but with German therefore you kind of
have to force your way in there and
appreciate it for what it is and
personally I found it
motivating to to deal with German and
deal with the challenges of German so
what are the challenges of German well
first of all German is not as difficult
for an English speaker as Russian
Chinese Japanese and so forth because
it's a related language and if you look
up you know lexical distance and stuff
on the internet you'll see that English
is quite close to German there are a lot
of common words some of which mean
different things some of which we can't
recognize but the word little you know
English and German have a common origin
and they also have a lot of similar loan
words from Latin or French so there's a
lot of common vocabulary that's on the
positive side the you know declensions I
mean there's only four cases if I'm not
mistaken which is a lot easier it
doesn't seem like a big difference
compared to six but I found that in
Russian the instrumental and the
prepositional and all of the reasons and
exceptions and everything surrounding
the use of cases which was much more of
an issue than in German I found that in
German you can almost ignore the cases
at least that's been my strategy I'm not
writing an exam I don't need my c2 in
German I can understand perfectly well
without knowing the cases I people
understand me when I get them wrong I
got motivated once to try and improve my
sense of the cases and I got this audio
book that dot TV eastn genitive zine
taught okay and they talk about when you
use the dative and when you use the
genitive and you know I I listen to it a
few times
like really I don't remember a thing it
had very little impact on me I really
don't care to be perfectly honest so
that those are my goals I feel that by
you know lots of listening and reading
and paying attention slowly I will get
better every attempt to study those
detention tables has been a failure but
it's not such a big problem I am more
conscious of that in Russian I make a
greater effort to try and
which case is this gonna be and that
slows me down
whereas in German I just winged it and I
don't care and in fact I'll say that it
was when I stopped trying to ace the
declension tables that my German
improved and I started focusing more on
acquiring more words and improving my
comprehension and listening to you know
as I mentioned the previous state tape
conversations between people and so
forth that I enjoyed it more I got
better I became more fluent I understood
more and I don't get hung up about these
case endings now any of you that are
studying at school writing for exams of
course you don't have the luxury you
have to sort of work on it so what are
the major problems in German
pronunciation I don't think is such a
big deal I you don't have to pronounce
with a guttural are you can pronounce
with a rolled R which they do in the
south of Germany you know all the vowels
are not such a big problem I think the
spelling is is consistent but it's it's
different from what we're used to in in
English but you just have to get used to
thee to what the what the letters
represent personally I find it
distracting that in German all of the
nouns are capitalized it's not done in
the other languages that I've learned I
know very well what's a noun and what
isn't a noun and in fact you know my
reaction to a word is based on the
meaning of that word in the context not
on whether it's capitalized or not so I
really don't understand why in German
they capitalized their nouns but they do
so as I always say you can't resist the
language you just have to go with the
flow I guess the biggest problem in
German is this whole issue of word order
you know if I can characterize it you
know if you learn German want then the
long convoluted sentences they use you
must get used to so the verb always
comes at the end I went to just for the
fun of it I went to deed site here
online and
the paragraph from an article about
President Obama and it says when the US
Congress knocked them ended as Zuma
pauza UBA I'm military I'm - in Syrian
on damn it
Ibaka on Frieden and shied it so if are
assuming that the US Congress after the
end of the summer pause summer break we
were over but it means on the subject of
militant ish iron - a military in grip
or intervention in Syria and in Syria
and with that dammit on the subject of
war which we all know and freedom peace
inside it he's gonna decide so if blah
blah blah blah is going to decide rather
a name if we would say if the US
Congress is gonna make up or may take a
decision on blah blah blah it would be
first
here it comes last so you gotta get used
to that it goes on state then Fulks for
threatened ina Sri they get up Vegas
fishing party interesting they're often
the shimano
of addition meinem even I am eigen and
give Eason before she did before it's
like imminent so you got it here and
before it there so those are the two
things one that the verb will often come
at the end and two that the verb is
often divided which part of the word the
verb at the front and part at the back
and typically those verbs that can be
divided our verbs that you know where
the emphasis is on the first syllable
basically that's it
the rest of it and so this is an issue
at first and any language when we start
learning it reading you know we know the
words and we kind of vaguely sense the
meaning but it's it's tough slogging it
seems little foggy for us we kind of
lose our thread and that goes on for a
long time we know the words and we kind
of get a sense of the meaning but it's
not the picture is not in sharp focus
what do we do keep reading and listening
that's all you can do and what seems
foggy at first eventually
eventually becomes easier because your
brain gets used to waiting for the verb
at the end for example gets used to the
fact that these you may have for the
first few times you don't notice that a
part of the verb is at the front and
another part of the verb is at the back
but the more you read and the more you
listen the more you get used to it and
you can always occasionally refer to a
grammar reference book and so forth and
that may also help you notice but
ultimately you just have to expose
yourself to enough of the language that
the brain will automatically pick up the
first half of the verb and patiently
wait for the other half of the verb to
arrive at the-- at the end of the
sentence and that's really the only
major difficulty in german german to my
mind is not that difficult language to
learn and I would particularly recommend
that we don't get too hung up unless you
have to write the c2 exam don't get too
hung up about the declensions if you
totally focus on the declensions on this
one specific aspect of the language and
don't get involved in more of the
vocabulary and more of a language and
exposing yourself to it just talking
without worrying about it I think your
language your progress will be impeded
so there you have it a follow-up video
and I did go ten minutes okay thanks for
listening bye for now